there are more signs of progress in the
country's battle with the omicron
variants the daily case count is down 86
percent since reaching a peak in most of
the u.s last month the decline is also
encouraging more cities and states to
reduce or eliminate their coronavirus
restrictions health officials say it's
still critical to vaccinate and get
booster shots michael george is here
with the latest michael good morning
jeff good morning no question there's
encouraging news new cases are dropping
and they're dropping fast down 43
percent just this week compared to last
week but still we're losing 2 000 lives
a day to covet as states roll back
restrictions doctors are reminding us
this pandemic isn't over yet
in indiana schools will no longer
require students who have been exposed
to covid19 to quarantine even in schools
where masks aren't required that leaves
health officials there encouraging
caution it's not as if we've cured covid
we definitely have more tools now to
fight it but it's not a given that
someone will have covenant will survive
many remain at high risk particularly
the elderly children too young to be
vaccinated and those who still refuse
vaccinations and if they get sick
there's another reality caregivers are
in shorter and shorter supply
in moorhead kentucky nurse courtney
hollingsworth herself still on the front
lines estimates about 40 percent of the
regional medical center's nursing staff
left during the pandemic we're reminding
ourselves why we went in to nursing
where we make a difference nearly 3 600
u.s health care workers have died of
covid one study found that 41 percent of
health care workers are considering
leaving the profession for good but not
dr aaron parker banks the only doctor in
a rural kentucky family clinic outside
lexington the only thing that is
semi-comparable and not even
not even close is like a battlefield and
we've been fighting now for two years
but we're the only people left to fight
and on friday new york's health
commissioner announced the state won't
enforce its booster shot requirement for
health care workers state officials
admit that enforcing that rule could
lead to staffing shortages at a time
when doctors and nurses are already
stretched to the limit michelle
they certainly are michael thank you the